this button no specifically it would
have been very useful to me as a child I
[Music]
grew up super Christian I lived in the
middle of nowhere it's on a farm raising
cattle small I'm sitting in Texas we had
to go to church every single Sunday
Monday and Wednesday where I'm at if you
didn't go to church there was something
wrong with you
we couldn't listen to any rap music and
watch music videos we couldn't do
anything that people my age 1 to do we
were required to have sex ed but it
didn't have to be medically accurate and
it was abstinence only we kind of
briefly learned what periods were but
what it came to hell like how to do
things and what things were meant for
what places that didn't really exist my
understanding of it was that sex is for
married people to make babies after I
had seen Star Wars Episode six I was
reading a Harry Styles fanfiction and I
realized that when I saw Leia in her
slave costume I was having special
feelings I was and a little Kim video
wasn't working oh when I was younger but
it ended up with me going into my room
and having some fun with some stuffed
animals that was the first time I felt
like hot and bothered really and I like
clear feelings down there and I didn't
know how to deal with it or what to do
so I'm going out I'm going at it and as
soon as I get finished my mom buses in
my room I'm like oh my I didn't know
what to do and then she noticed that the
covers were all the way up to my office
you could feel it in my face she whips
the covers off of me it look like I had
a baseball bat in my bag I'm still there
you know next thing I know we're in the
car on the way to the preachers house so
I would go to the winter bucket where we
kept all of our scarves and I would tie
them around myself to sort of look like
Slave Leia we go over there
the pastor we're holding hands meeting
him and my mom they make me by my hair
the pastor is like god I just want you
to break this demon that Kendall has in
them we don't know where it came
we know that he wasn't raised like this
and his family's disappointed in him and
I am too but we know that you we know
that you have the power I'm just sitting
there like oh my I cannot believe this
is happening can you imagine everything
I learned about sex was via the internet
I started reading magazines I remember
just being obsessed with Cosmo because
of the fact that it gave me more
information than I was getting but you
know I don't need 50 million tips on how
to tickle his pickle or whatever I think
it's very important to have sex ed in
schools when I was in high school I
think we had three teen pregnancies not
a lot of friends that got talked into
things or we're drunk when it happened
and didn't realize until many years
later that they hadn't consented like it
wasn't sex I absolutely think that
people can be sexual and also be
religious there's so many contradictions
in the Bible and as an adult I can't
ignore those contradictions you know but
at the same time I know that there is a
God I'm still I'm still Christian if you
do believe in that higher power you're
created to be the person who you were
meant to be no matter what that entail
you are who you are and you're entitled
to that self love and God is gonna love
you no matter what and then she's on top
of the ball my goodness this or this
scene right here made me want to lose my
virginity this scene right here too hot
for TV oh my god that's how you need
ready for to be watching